[Music]
so I was doing some work in our
Collegiate Dictionary and I was doing
some reading in the letter B and I ran a
ran across the entry for bitch and I
noticed to fit the entry for bitch had
many meanings but didn't actually have
any labels on it that said those
meanings were offensive or vulgar or
derogatory which really surprised me so
I went through this deep dig through our
archives to see why that is and the the
word bitch
was originally used of a female dog and
that goes back all the way into Old
English over a thousand years but by
about 1400 it had also come to refer to
a lewd woman or an immoral woman and
then shortly thereafter it was also used
to refer to a domineering woman or a
woman who was like a man and you see
this really interesting proliferation of
meaning for the word bitch in the 1500
1600 and 1700s where bitch when applied
to a woman is always a pretty much
negative and bitch is also applied to
men at this point and it's applied to
men in a way that feminized 'iz them so
gay men were called bitch back in the
1600s and a weak and ineffectual men
were called bitch so what's really
fascinating is you see this movement
through history and historical
dictionaries did say bitch was the worst
thing that you could possibly call a
woman they ignored all of the uses of
men's which is also a really fascinating
thing no one entered those uses for
hundreds and hundreds of years in their
dictionaries even though they were very
common so what happened is I wanted to
know why this didn't have a label on it
so I went through and looked back at our
defining history because we have that
all that history in the office and I
found that really from about the 1930s
onward there were different editors who
argued a that we include any sense the
referred to men because that was
important that was historical use
and those those notes were often
rejected so nothing appeared for a while
and then in the 60s the person who is in
charge of editing the entry for bitch
was woman and she had included in her
notes some strong labels saying that
these this is an abusive term and and
those got dropped just they were dropped
for no apparent reason so so then we
come up into the 90s which is when the
last big revision to the word bitch was
made for our Collegiate Dictionary and
it gets a usage note says it's used as a
generalized term of abuse so okay we now
we have a usage note they're not the
same as saying it's offensive revolt
grrrrrr but we're heading in the right
direction and the two times in in the
modern company history where that was
done it was done at the instance of a
woman someone who had actually lived
what it's like to be called a bitch
constantly so so what's really
fascinating is if you see this arc of
meaning that is very clearly derogatory
and lexicographers just didn't I mean in
general didn't pick it up for a while if
they entered the word at all they didn't
actually define it they just said it was
a terrible word to call a woman or once
they started defining it there were
enough issues around but or there were
enough instances of a bitch used as a
reclaimed slur women saying you know why
Matt ufff bitch which reads like a
positive thing so it's this very
interesting interplay of here's a
negative word and everyone sort of knows
in their gut that it's a negative word
you don't call a woman a bitch but women
are calling themselves bitches and it's
the end it's it's meant as a compliment
to themselves so how do lexicographers
deal with that with this idea that that
slurs get reclaimed but how do you
describe it and and every person has a
different reaction to the word bitch and
that depends on the content
that's used in who uses it what kind of
mood they're in when they hear it
whether it's directed at them or not
whether they're using it of someone else
so it's a really difficult thing as a
lexicographer to come up with a just a
one-line definition that covers all of
those varied uses